problema 121 problemas 121 nos dice si x
entre 2 es igual a 3 entre james x entre
2 es igual a 3 entre y sucede que x es
menor que y la pregunta es x es menor
que ye
ok en el inciso 1 de información lo que
nos dicen es que es mayor o igual que 3
que es mayor o igual que 3 déjame
trabajar un poquito con esta condición
para verla más cómodamente multiplicando
por acá y por 2 de este lado se ha
multiplicando cruzado
tenemos que xy es igual a 6 es igual a 6
aquí tenemos información acerca de ye y
nos gustaría tener información acerca de
x así que voy a dividir entre y x es
igual
a 6 / ok creo que con esto ya puedo
trabajar un poco más cómodamente a ver
aquí me dice que ya es mayor o igual que
3 eso que me dice acerca de x bueno pues
sí que es grande x es 6 dividido entre
algo grande entre algo mayor o igual que
3 vale entonces el menor valor que puede
el menor valor o el mayor el mayor valor
que puede tomar x es cuando lleva al e3
verdad porque sigue valiera más entonces
x vale menos vamos a hacerlo es decir si
le pongo ye igual a 3 me queda que x es
igual a 6 medios que es igual a 2 y por
lo tanto x siempre es menor o igual que
2 vale o sea si ya toma el valor extremo
entonces x alcanza su máximo y si ya
aumenta x se va haciendo más pequeño
entonces esta información me dice que x
es menor o igual que 2 y por lo tanto si
puedo responder si x es menor que ya
verdad x es menor o igual que 2 y es
mayor o igual que 3
entonces x es menor
muy bien entonces este inciso si nos
ayuda a responder la pregunta vamos a
ver qué dice el inciso 2 en el inciso 2
nos dicen que es menor o igual que 4 y
es menor o igual que 4
ok esto pues es muy parecido pero hay
que tener cuidado vamos a ver qué nos
dice esto en términos de x ahora ya no
es demasiado grande ya es menor o igual
que 4 entonces ahora x va a tomar un
mínimo verdad x va a ser mayor o igual
que 6 /
entre 4 que es igual a 3 medios a tres
medios vale porque porque ahora es menor
o igual que alguien y por lo tanto x va
a estar dividido entre cosas cada vez
más y más pequeñas que jay y por lo
tanto va a ser un número más y más
grande entonces esto nos dice que x es
mayor o igual que tres medios tres
medios y no sé si esto nos vaya a decir
algo más se me hace que no se me hace
que no porque ahora nos quedó al revés
la cadenita de desigualdades a ver vamos
a hacer una tabla qué sucede cuando oye
es igual a 3 a ver sigue aquí lo voy a
poner déjame ponerle por aquí
y de este lado x
entonces si es igual a 3 tenemos si es
igual a 3 si es igual a mejor dejar de
ponerle 4 que es el valor máximo si que
es igual a 4x es tres medios si es igual
a 3
entonces x es igual a 6 entre 32 y si es
igual a 2 entonces x es 3
aquí ya le gana x pero aquí x le gana
allí entonces en este inciso tenemos las
dos posibilidades y entonces no podemos
responder esta pregunta así que el
inciso 2 no es suficiente y por lo tanto
la respuesta sería ah muy bien vamos al
problema 122
122 en el problema 122 nos dicen que b&w
son enteros distintos b&w enteros
enteros distintos distintos esto debe
ser importante distintos ok
y lo que nos pregunta la pregunta es si
b es igual a 0
bueno pues vamos a ver qué dice el
inciso 1 en el inciso 1 la información
que nos dan es que vw un wv es igual a
be cuadrada es igual
ave cuadrada a ver pensemos tantito qué
sucede aquí será cierto que b es igual a
cero pues bueno si b es igual a cero se
da esta igualdad pero qué pasa si ves
distinto de cero qué pasa si b es
distinto de cero si b es distinto de
cero entonces podemos cancelar b porque
podemos dividir entre b ya que es un
número distinto de cero vale entonces
nos quedaría que w sería igual a d
pero esto de aquí no es posible verdad
no es posible porque bay w son enteros
distintos entonces esta igualdad o sea
esta igualdad que causa esta igualdad
causa o bien que w sea igual a b o bien
que sea igual a 0 a lo mejor lo puedo
reescribir así de cuadrada menos b w
es igual a cero voy a factorizar un ave
v por bm w
es igual a 0 y creo que aquí es mucho
más claro verdad aquí este producto de
dos cosas es igual a cero entonces una
de ellas debe ser igual a cero pero ésta
no puede ser cero porque veis w son
distintos
entonces concluimos que b es igual a
cero vale entonces este sí nos permite
determinar si b es igual a cero o no de
hecho nos dice que es igual a cero
y el inciso 2 dice lo siguiente del
inciso 2 dice que w es igual a 2 puesto
que esto está súper chafa si w es igual
a 2 pues no tenemos información de efe
entonces éste claramente no nos va a dar
la información que necesitamos entonces
la respuesta sería ah vale
la respuesta es ah
muy bien vamos ahora al problema 123 123
color naranja en el problema 123 nos
preguntan por el valor de 36.500 500 x
1.05 elevado a la n nos piden determinar
cuánto es esto
ok vamos a ver qué información tenemos
en el inciso 1 nos dicen que n cuadrada
menos 5 n 6
es igual a cero podemos resolver esta
cuadrática factor izando hay que
encontrar dos números que sumados o
resta 2 del 5 y que multiplicados den 6
y me parece que funciona en m2
x nm 3 - 2 x menos 13 6 menos 23 es
menos 5
entonces que esto sea 0 es lo mismo a
pedir que esto sea igual a 0 lo cual nos
da dos posibilidades que n sea igual a 2
o bien que n sea igual a 3 y si no
sabemos cuál es el valor de n si tenemos
esta incertidumbre no podemos calcular
este numerito de acá porque no sabemos
si está n tiene que ser dos o tres
entonces esta información por sí misma
no es suficiente y en el inciso 2 lo que
nos dice es que n 2 es distinto de 0
básicamente que en es distinto de menos
2 dedos porque sumamos 2 de ambos lados
si tenemos esta información de aquí por
sí misma no es suficiente porque n
podría ser cero o podría ser 20.000 o
podrá o podría ser no sé 123 entonces es
la del ver por sí misma no nos dice nada
pero si juntamos las dos
si juntamos las dos entonces sabemos que
es dos o tres pero que no es dos
entonces ésta se elimina y en ese día
tres y podemos calcular esto recuerda
que no nos interesa calcularlo
exactamente sería una lata enorme hacer
1.05 al cubo y luego multiplicar por
esto en este examen únicamente nos
interesa que podemos hacerlo vale
entonces juntando las dos si podemos y
así la respuesta sería c
déjame hacer un último problema todavía
nos quedan algunos un par de minutos
quizás tres vamos a hacer el 124 y aquí
tenemos un plano cartesiano tenemos el
eje y el eje x
en algo así y también tenemos dibujado
un triángulo algo más o menos de este
estilo algo así algo así aquí tenemos
que este punto se llama y este es el eje
de james este es el eje x este punto de
acá se llama
y este punto de acá se llama b se llama
be ok entonces ese de ahí es el dibujo
nos dicen que es menor que pq ope es
menor que pq
y la pregunta la pregunta es si el área
de la región o pq es mayor que 48 si el
área de o p q es mayor que 48 si quieres
le pongo área
esta de aquí es la pregunta bueno pues
vamos a ver qué información nos dan en
el inciso 1 lo que nos dicen es que las
coordenadas del punto p son 6 868
entonces este punto p sería 6,8 ok si
son 68 este puntito de acá
en el eje x es el 6 y la altura la
altura es 8 verdad este estoy acá es 8
con eso conocemos la altura del
triángulo pero no conocemos su base así
que debe estar muy difícil poder
encontrar poder encontrar si el área es
mayor que 48 entonces yo creo que este
nos sirve
y en el inciso 2 lo que nos dice es que
las coordenadas del punto q son 13 0 13
estoy acá es 13
pero aunque hay pues aquí tenemos que
decir bueno de aquí son 13 tendríamos la
altura y podemos ver si es más o menos
de 48 verdad sería 13 por 8
entre 2 que es igual a 13 por 4 que es
igual a 52 que le gana a 48 entonces
juntando la información de los dos
incisos si podemos responder la pregunta
y por separado me parece que nos sirven
pero aquí hay algo raro porque me dieron
esta condición
y no sé si sirva para algo así que
déjame pensarlo tantito pero p
es menor que pq
a no sabes que se me hace que el inciso
1 si era suficiente a ver ahí te va a
ver déjame pensarlo sí creo que sí a ver
hay tema
sí sí éste es 6 y este es 8 sabemos que
el área de este triángulo es 6 por 848
entre 224 el de acá
pero la única forma en la cual sea menor
que pq es cuando cuesta más alejado del
6 que a esta pregunta tiene mucho truco
verdad entonces pues o sea sí sí ope es
menor que pq de 6 aquí es más grande que
de 6 a 0 entonces de cubo o sea de 6 es
más que 6 esto es más que 6 y entonces
esta área sería más que 24 y por lo
tanto el área conjunta sería más que 48
y por lo tanto tan sólo sabiendo la
información del inciso 1 podemos
responder la pregunta vaya a eso sí que
estaban súper con truco pero fíjate una
cosa que resultó de mucha utilidad es
pensar en donde en donde se utilizaba la
hipótesis vale bueno vamos a dejarle
hasta aquí la respuesta de este problema
sería sería a el inciso 1 es suficiente
el 2 por supuesto que no sólo nos da
esta base y eso pues está muy aburrido
porque p podría estar a cualquier altura
pero bueno la respuesta es y le dejamos
hasta aquí y nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo para seguir haciendo de estos
problemas